rolling how do we crazy oh my gosh we
with the oh my gosh guys hey welcome to
the corridor cast Jordan Allen came up
to me today and he was like hey what's
your what's the worst way to die yeah
you know I I walked in this morning and
I looked at the stove we have a stove in
the studio and there was like a nice
thick layer of just burnt skin on the
stove yep uh and I knew that it belonged
to a fish that Nick had eaten previously
fish I think it was fish or some sort of
beast of the land prob bacon
[Laughter]
like I tossed a whole fish on that's a
pre- beast of the land so regardless uh
you know they got me thinking about the
Brazen bull the Brazen bull is that what
it's called the Brazen bull dud now this
you know I don't know too much about
history but Nick is a is a big history
buff Nick AKA Matt is a big history buff
over here we love it yeah and uh and you
know I got to talking to him about the
worst ways to die in history and it was
fascinating and we decided why not say
that
with other people here as well so that
you know mean everyone can enjoy the the
horrors Jordan says she has some
favorite worst ways to die in history
and Griffin also knows a lot about this
Stu favorite as in I would never want it
to happen to me but wow they came up
with this how cool it it's horrible to
genuinely think that real people who
again were the main character in their
own story here end it that way that was
the end of their script and that's
horrible to think about Brazen bow in
particular for some reason seeing that
fish skin on the stove
that stove top like the for those of you
who don't know the Brazen Bowl basically
is this giant metal Bowl I don't know
what it's made of it was I think bronze
back in the day yeah it would have been
a big copper bowl big copper bowl and
they would put people inside of it and
then light a fire underneath it until
the person died and if you think about
it it honestly is like a stove top just
getting hotter where your skin would
melt onto the bowl so the end day You'
just be a little freaking gusher just
it's like a little melted gusher on the
side I don't know yeah that's honestly
it happened like there there's records
of this it was like a king in in Sicily
in the southern Sicilian City I think
ofas it was like this you know all these
city states around there and there were
all these like these Kings who came up
and were just like you know horrible
Ruthless People they were all fighting
over this tiny little you know Island
and yeah I I forget his name but this
guy who took over the city state decided
let me make this big brazen
start boiling people and cooking people
literally alive well I think it goes to
show that people had way more time on
their hands is that it was and honestly
I I swear I think to this day the only
reason we still don't do that to people
is because we just don't have that much
time it's a time thing it's a Time dud I
I think like for that though if if I was
to put myself in his mindset it would be
probably to send a message because I
mean execution was something the state
did and it was like yo you better you
better listen listen to me I'm your king
or else I'm going to put you in this
bowl and boil you and the the scary
thing about that Bullman is apparently
you know the screams of the person being
cooked inside echoed through there was a
mouthpiece that was like a horn
apparently you know and it would
actually like warp the screams into the
sound of like a bull uh you know running
around or whatever bulls do I don't know
what does a bull they run around dude
they just run around say I think they
chill until there's a human in front of
it it was the Bronze bolt too yeah
that's what it's called so the thing is
uh what's his name while you're wed
comping it yeah I'm on this thing dude
we out here dang son
so oh yep valeris Tyrant of arras dude
you're on it but apparently he met his
end in the bll oh that's isn't that
poetic that is poetic depends on who you
ask if you're gonna come up with a
horrible way to kill your citizens you
should die that way yeah you know just
like you know if we're gonna be telling
people about a product we should be
using it ourselves it's so true it's so
true uh cut to vessie
sponsorship keeps you warm you can't see
it but ag1
greens yeah so I mean it did get me
thinking because obviously you know I
think we've all we've all seen our fair
share of brutal history but what what is
on your guys list of like because bronze
Bowl to me would definitely be up there
but I don't I'm sure there's something
worse I'm sure there's something worse
so I open the floor I'm curious what you
guys have to offer here's the thing with
like why they become worse the whole
point was to find methods to torture
people that would keep them alive as
long as possible because that was the
whole that was the game whether they
were trying to get information out of
them or not they just like I said they
had the time on their hands and they
wanted to torture because the longer
you're alive the more you get tortured
so that's like the idea of it so when
you're thinking of these how to die
basically the longer that you're alive
there's some that you would last last
eight days no so that one that's the
impalement one that the r yeah dude oh
my God impal I know
everyone so what what about the impaling
it's like technically yeah if you just
went straight through the organs you
could die because of internal bleeding
but people got crafty and knew how to
like kind of weave it up the spine and
around the organs or it goes up your
butt by the way and you could live for
like up to
oh vladin palor no joke like he was a
real person I've heard of him and he had
a big war against the byzantines and
apparently most of the prisoners and all
the people he like you know uh let's say
got rid of during all his political
coups and stuff he would impale them
that was his preferred method and
Jordan's absolutely right it would take
days for these people to die because he
had impaled so many people or his
impaling uh Team you know his impaling
yeah you know his his his people CFO and
he had a whole team of these people who
were professionals and they yeah like
Jordan said like they can get the spike
through you would go through the bottom
and then around your organs and up
through like your neck here so it would
actually kind of like support your
weight you know and then they'd put you
up oh oh so it's not like over time for
some reason I was thinking over time it
was like moving up they were moving up
like you were like sitting on it I think
the whole idea was they wanted them
sitting up cuz it was kind of like a
warning of like we will do this to you
too so they would have them all on the
on the sticks just like out for the
world and dude we are talking thousands
of people dude would be impaled there
were literal impaling like I don't want
to say party but there was like impaling
festivals where he would be like oh you
know what how about everyone in this
room is actually GNA get impaled now and
then they he'd be like and the
guard like you know it's like Game of
Thrones [__] like he's worried his
political opponents are going to you
know turn on him so he get rid of people
um anyway dude that is like to me one of
the most
freaky ideas of just like knowing you're
about to get impaled mhm like even worse
than crucifixion because I think he got
probably inspired by the Romans with the
crucifixion you know it was a kind of a
also a stick related exposure death yeah
you know they put you up usually nail
you um but nail you through the I'd much
rather take the nails than than
the I'm out once that yeah I'd rather do
the nails too even that one you stay up
there for so long cuz you either die of
infection or they they were saying you
you're held up by your arms and so your
lungs start to collapse so like you
basically start like running out of
breath because you can't breathe anymore
all the blood probably like fills it up
oh I'm looking at pictures now yeah yeah
it's something like the the weight of
your body against your joints like over
time slowly like the the stretching of
your joints and your ligaments and all
that like eventually just presses more
and more on your lungs oh which bring
which brings me to my next one bring it
on if I'm if I'm up there let me give me
that you said like the stretching of
joints the there's the thing called The
Rack where you would be on laid out and
your arms would be tied to one and legs
tied to the other one and they would
turn crank you the stretcher yeah and
you it like you wouldn't technically die
it would just be over time your bones
and ligaments are coming apart so even
if they let you go you wouldn't be able
to walk anywhere you wouldn't be able to
do anything cuz spaghetti boy mhm so
that was a torture method of like we
want stuff out like we want information
out of you dude torture is crazy because
like it's definitely it was sanctioned
like for most of History by whatever
ruling parties and even like recently
obviously I mean Guantanamo right yeah
but like yes it's all about keeping them
alive a good torture you know you can't
get too hasty you know because you also
don't want them to like pass out
necessarily no yeah totally yeah I mean
usually it's to get information really
screwed up part is though like a lot of
times like
they knew the person everyone involved
knew the person wasn't going to live it
was just about getting a confession uhuh
and like I read this book called like
Paris city of um light city of poison
and It Go talks about Paris had like the
first like you know kind of police force
honestly that was like really structured
but they would you know get sanctioned
to torture criminals and most of them
knew they weren't going to live they
were just like you should confess now so
you go to heaven when you die do it
immediately yeah instead of like go to
hell when you die slowly like so it was
more of like a we'll torture you so you
confess so we'll kill you fast yeah so
you don't have to be tortured anymore
which is really screwed up to think
about that that's Justice right oh dude
yeah back in those days CU there's
nothing you can even do about it too and
it could all be kept from the public so
stinking easily dude I mean people would
just disappear yeah why not like there I
went to uh this this is not nearly as
bad as what we're talking about but it's
still pretty horrific but I was in the
London dungeons when I was out in London
visiting family oh that's where you're
from that's where I'm from yeah yeah we
we invented this thing actually my good
exhibit yeah yeah it's crazy but there
was a hook that they would just
basically put up the old the old back
hole you know and they'd hoist you up to
the ceiling like a big and it was like a
big rusty metal hook and they would just
hook you from the back and hoist you up
to the ceiling and you're literally
hanging from the hook until you confess
they just there's like s music on this
episode of
Seinfeld uh what's the deal with h
what's the deal with these
hooks um but then of course England has
the rat one that you were telling me
about Nick rat dude I hate the rat the
rat one we this one's famous from Game
of
Thrones oh I think I know what you're
talking about let me see if I know what
is it Jordan tell us about the rat the
rat okay it's actually how my yeah it's
it's like the British love doing this
it's how my great-grandfather passed oh
yeah yeah oh okay he had a heart attack
while he was doing this to somebody
else it's common in Pub fights pull out
a bucket freaking torch and a rat hold
um but no the essentially it would be
you know if they want again I think it's
a torture or just killing thing uh but
they would put a rat up against your
stomach and trap it with a bucket and
then uh light a fire on the back end of
the bucket and so the rat naturally not
being able to escape any of the metal
would go to the softest part which is
you and it would burrow through you to
get out yeah so you got a little gber
going in there and just eating your body
cheese man eating that cheese eating
that cheese eating that sweet there was
another one with rats and stuff but it
it it was like everything in the
ecosystem around you they would lay them
where like their arms and head were out
then cover you with like another Wooden
Boat so You' be in a boat and then
another Wooden Boat they would
forcefully put honey and like milk in
you whatever yeah and then fill you up
make sure your stomach's all nice and
full and then you'd start like expelling
gas and all the little critters would
just start coming and gnawing on you and
then you're expelling more gas so then
that's when like the worms start coming
the worms yeah like worms those swimming
worms they come up to you no you're not
you're not even in the you're not even
in the oh you just put you in a boat
yeah you're not even in the water yet
this they they put you in the water
after you die but you just kind of go
days with the with the Eco system kind
of I mean exposure in insects that's
like the worst part die being eaten
alive cuz think about the sensation of
everything on your body paper cuts hurt
worse than bigger Cuts sometimes yeah
okay that many tiny little cuts do you
know the feeling when like you're like
oh something's crawling on me like an
ant so imagine that times like a million
I guess I don't even want to I think it'
be quite literally a million and then
there's something like gnawing on you
then it's in you and you feel and you
feel it like tickling up your throat
biting and it's just whenever your body
decides happy Halloween everyone die
happy H yeah legit this is totally a
Halloween episode hey Griffin yeah
what's your what's your biggest like
fear in terms of dying like
what what chills your blood when you
think about it well you know I'm not a
big fan of this first of all I'm not a
big fan of this one that I just found
related to the rats um there was this
Roman um Rich dude just this total
meanie who would like just apparently
like throw people into a big pit of eels
and they would eat them alive which is
another fun way to get creative with you
know animals never thought about never
thought dude honestly I think like
hunger
being it's kind of a tie between being
mauled by a predator and drowning I
think drowning is maybe one of the
scariest deaths and um I agree with it
goes so kind of fast though compared to
other ways to die right it does and I
heard it's peaceful you no one no I
think I think it's because it's like
your air like everything's getting
blocked so it's like at some point
there's not even like a like you you
know what I mean yeah for me it's like
the moment of realization of like oh
there's no more air and then it's like
that 10 seconds must really really
really suck yeah Panic dude did you see
lives it's it's about the uh oh yes yes
yes that was good dude really good movie
great film if anyone's looking for just
a banger of a movie to watch watch 13
lives it is so good it's a real life
superhero movie and so under the radar I
totally yeah amazing but there's a
there's a freaking like spoiler there's
a a drowning scene in that movie and it
freaked me out I hate it I hate it yeah
but it's such a good movie it's so
realistic too and it's like there's also
no spoilers there's a dude who almost
drowns that is a spoiler though
sorry show it shows the Panic that sets
in right and like how you just stop
thinking and for me there are two my two
by far biggest fear ways to go is cave
exploring like cave crawling those guys
like a mine or something that collapses
and you're just stuck in there is it
there was I don't know if it's still up
but the internet historian did a video
on a kid who got who was exploring caves
and got stuck I think it was like a
three-day ordeal and eventually well you
have to time it perfectly for like high
tide and like that's when you can get in
and out that that one's just the the
actual cave exploring like above ground
caves like you get stuck upside down
I've had dreams of this man where you
get stuck upside down you like you're
trying to crawl through a gap that's too
small and The Rock shifts a little bit
and you can't get back out pitch black
you're all alone you're just stuck
underground like mov because you've
scraped your way like through all these
gaps where you have to inhale just to
get through and then you can't get back
out that's what's that one Ted Ted the
Cav no Ted the Cav is a fake one yeah
and then the other one is um is
basically that underwater it's it's what
it's what 13 lives is about 13 lives
right yeah yeah where it's the
underground cave div and people do that
for fun and like you're you're totally
underwater you have a mask there's like
almost no visibility so they have a line
that you have to hold on to if you get
separated from from the line or you see
somebody else get separated from the
line the rule is you do not go after
them you do not leave the line because
if they start freaking out and they kick
up like the sediment or whatever and
your visibility goes to zero there's a
very high chance that you die as well
yeah I I truly believe that there's like
certain activities that should only be
left to like highly experienced
professionals because even they die even
they die so it's like the fact that you
can just buy a $250 ticket to go do
these type of things kind of freaks me
out I will never do that 13 lives I will
never it's it's really really sad too
how many stories there are of people
going cave diving and like it's one of
those activities where there's like
literally more ways for it to kill you
than not and like so many of these
stories you can look up on YouTube or or
whatever of people going out and doing
that and they're being like like just
dying because there's a sign that's like
do not go further if you're not an
experienced cave diver and they do it
anyway or like going off the line or you
know being like Oh I don't need special
mix even though I'm going 300 me down
like there's even stories of like like
you were saying like people going down
like not paying attention to those
warnings dying and then like the pro
like retrieval driver like like the pro
retrieval divers dying trying to get
them back like yep it's nuts yeah did
you guys what is that movie with uh the
met the
the whale movie Jason St you see the
whale movie no the shark movie of is a
whale big enough but it's like even he
he was the most experienced person to go
like underwater and even he had issues
so it's like couldn't beat that sharp
that was a biopic by the way true story
crazy really it's based off true story
no on the life of Jason St it might be
the Meg 2 came out by way there's going
to be a sequel to anything like that
that's all but movie like that will
always have a sequel that's the
guarantee I heard it was really good
yeah everyone was like this movie is
rocks any like giant monster thing I'm
down just have fun with it dude yeah but
I don't know I'm more about like maybe
air activities cuz we're way more
experienced in the air that's also one
of my fears is like freaking airplane
crash dude like that would I I would
probably be one of those people freaking
out in those videos where it's like we
thought the plane was going to go down
of course all calm well cuz it's the
amount of time it's like if you die
skydiving right I've thought about this
it's like it's scary but it's a it's
about 30 second like but when the shoot
doesn't open I mean maybe a minute I
don't know it's a while before you get
down the actual like impact it's it's
over it's like it's done immediately
your brain probably wouldn't even
register that's how I want maybe give me
that quick like surprise death yeah like
I don't even know what's happening and
then it's done give me that Titan sub
like flat yeah that's like 006 seconds
or something take there when it's time
just yeah just compress yeah but yeah in
the plane like the thing that freaks me
out about the planes is like especially
over water it's like if it hits and you
make it only to then be in a sinking
metal container oh god with hundreds of
other people who are clawing to get out
oh that might be the most horrific thing
yeah cuz no one in the exit row knows
how to work it no I've sat there and I
didn't know how to work it you just give
you give the verbal yes but yeah they
just basically ask you please say yes
and you say yes and they say okay great
I thought you're just the one who gets
SI
it kind of is that way oh co I've only a
few plane crashes how many how many
stories are there of like surviving uh a
sinking ship or a plane crash and then
just like dope we're in an inflatable
raft for three weeks and the sharks are
coming like we can see them and we know
that like we're just going to like die
of sunburn or dehydration cuz why is it
that that they can never find people
either oh they went off the radar think
it would be a easier Ocean's big bro
ocean is pretty big big I feel like if
they wanted to find us they would yeah
if they wanted to find us they would you
should tell them that hey FAA um you
know we are tweeting at you right now
yeah you don't want you don't want me
bad there was a documentary about an
airplane crash it was called like number
it was the plane that number you know
your flight number it's labeled that and
they just disappeared never gone never
found
kind of gosh they went off the radar and
no one no one knows where they are no
like no remains or anything no bodies no
anything but I mean think about like
have you ever tried to find a friend who
just like has their phone turned off I'm
good at it like you know that they're
like you're at the fair or something and
they're being you know all present and
their you know their phones on do not
disturb and you really need to find them
like that's a task but like
the Pacific is pretty big and once that
plane goes down and they're in that raft
and they're like drifting and they're
floating and they're paddling like but I
mean we we we have satellites now we do
now we do but like dude have you guys
heard about the USS
Indianapolis the worst shark attack in
history documented that we have
documented I'm sure there were some big
ass shark attacks back in the day when
everyone fought on boats more D when the
Megaladon talking is the Us Indianapolis
is this a boat yeah yeah so in World War
II it's this huge US Navy boat that got
hit by a Japanese torpedo and there were
like a thousand something people and
like I think 900 of them like lived
through the big ass explosion that went
up when the torpedo hit and then they're
just floating there in the ocean 900
Sailors and like I think like a couple
hundred survived and they were literally
slowly eaten alive by sharks as they
floated in the water the Sharks would
you know pick them off one by one oh my
gosh and no like and Shar didn't like
the taste of humans no they they do yeah
if there's blood in the water and
there's wounded people and there's
corpses humans don't out in the middle
of the
ocean we we've found out that they do
like the taste of humans cuz like
hundreds and hundreds of sailors got one
by one can you imagine how horrific and
you just know where to go waiting until
it's your turn where to go you're a
bobbing Apple dud legit you're just
waiting like there was a there was a kid
who was recently attacked in Egypt by a
shark really and he was like not that
far off the shoreline yeah I'm going to
attacked so like he lived no oh no
there's a video of it okay so it says
here that the animals apparently were
drawn by the sound of the explosions and
the sinking of the ship and all the
blood yeah so like there was probably a
lot of casualties so all that blood you
know they say blood attract sharks and
it does uh my dad and I for his one of
his birthdays we went shark diving
together no way so s with great whites
right like the the gold cage yeah
definitely in a cage but the the goal is
to see one and where we were they hadn't
seen a great white in I think it was
like 5 days or something like that so we
kind of didn't have our hopes up and of
the multiple ships that were out there
just trying to find anything uh we threw
a foam seal like the shape of a seal out
on the water and like an hour into our
Voyage out of and I wasn't scared of the
ocean before this mind you but out of
the darkness just this mouth ascends out
of nowhere and Chomps the thing clean in
half and it was these things get up to
like I think 20 feet or 22 feet or
something great whites unless you're
talking this one was 13 feet and it
looked humongous and I'm like that alone
and the violence that it did it with and
then everyone like hopped in the cage
and the cage lowered into the water and
it like rammed the cage once and it's
like the violence and speed because uh
they can sense and I might botch this so
any anyone who works with sharks
apologies but uh they they can sense you
in the water they essentially sense your
electromagnetic energy or something
sense your Fe they sense your fear from
a very long way away and so if you're
even in the water and are scared they
will know your prey and just be curious
and they might just take a curiosity
bite and if they don't want it they'll
leave it but guess what that's still
your leg and it's now gone so if that
happen with all these Sailors and it's
like oh look at all these like minced
pies floating on the surface you know
one by one it's like hey it's better
than nothing most terrifying thing I
like I really like the ocean though
because I'm like big on I see dolphins I
jump in
and I and you love that part of the
ocean what about like the depths what
about like but like but that's out deep
like we were like just on a sailboat
like just going from like Santa Monica
up to Malibu we're like far out I love
being over jump in it's like you know
it's so deep that it's like it's just
cold and dark and it just yeah Bo that
freaks me out but I've never thought
about sharks for some reason they're
worth they're worth thinking about
thinking about yeah they're worth
thinking about not not dwelling too hard
on cuz they're not usually going to f
with you but sh TS aren't very do you
think they're becoming more common or
are we just hearing about them more I
don't think they're that common I really
don't think they're that common okay um
and most sharks are seem quite friendly
like on another another trip with my dad
I got to stop going out with my dad uh
we did we did another shark thing he
stayed in the boat because he's
intelligent and I got in because the the
guide there said that it's okay to do
which I don't know you and we're foreign
this is what I mean even the experts are
idiot yeah and he's just like no it's
chill you can go in and I'm like okay we
just met and this is crazy but just hop
on in and you you know won't die what
happen so he so I jumped in and he
started throwing Chum in the water shut
the [__] up and these sharks were were
quite big like I'm not exaggerating they
were like more than my wingspan you had
a cage right no no no free and I was on
the other side of the boat like ducking
my head over and seeing them all like
mash on this Chum and then he says you
can go around to the other side and I
trust this guy cuz I met him just now
and he's not in the water with you he's
just like up there
go over yeah and we're just there's no
authorities your dad like I'm good on
that yeah so I'm I'm in there and I
joined them on the other side of the
boat just to get as close as possible to
them just like eating this food and
they're so strong and chaotic and dude
one of the scariest moments of my life I
like turn around I have these little
goggles on and I turn around and I look
and out of the blue it's the biggest one
of the lot and it's just coming swimming
directly for me and I like get so meek
and I press myself up against the bottom
of the boat like this I'm just pressed
against the Bott I'm like oh my gosh oh
my gosh oh my gosh like when the nas
ghouls are are walking by and I feel it
on my back dude it like it like presses
and slimes against my back and I'm just
like oh my gosh and I crawl back up in
the boat immediately but yeah they
didn't eat me they ate the chum you
thought that was a good it it didn't go
as planned I didn't plan for that well
what what kind of shck you said like
this line were they like black tip reef
Shar I really and I'm so mad cuz I don't
remember the name of them and I don't
remember what kind of sharks they were
but I think they're just friendly shark
they're like not they're not that into
humans it's not like a tiger shark or
anything I think those are the really
dangerous ones but uh imagine if they
had been though oh dude and that's the
thing is like I didn't know and I got in
anyway I'm a ding-dong like what a way
to go that's one no one you would have
just gotten clowned on Instagram yeah
cuz definitely my dad would have posted
about it for sure he would have logged
in my Instagram and go my son got eaten
cuz he's an idiot it would have made its
way to Instagram some way somehow
God that's what you think Che out this
check out this kid in
2005 dude you would have been on Tosh.0
that's that's definitely the worst
part yeah Griffin have you seen Grizzly
Man the movie or yeah
documentary Grizzly is real cuz I know
Grizzly Man Who like hangs out around
like the corner of Santa Fe and yeah
yeah man no I
mean there's like this documentary about
this man who befriended apparently
befriended bear quotes oh yeah all
involved it was pretty apparent he had
beend Bears until it was apparent that
he hadn't yeah and they show that in the
movie and it's like I'm still scarred
from like middle school when they
wielded in that [__] TV and showed us
that movie they showed you the nend too
yeah they didn't tell me there were
screams of people dying and being eaten
alive dude you hear it
and it's like he eventually him and his
wife or girlfriend are in their tent and
they're just recording audio or was it
video as well I can't remember uh
there's a video I'm not sure well they
edit it in the documentary I believe to
video I'm not sure if the video was
taken the same time I don't it's been a
long time I haven't watched the movie
again I don't want to I don't want to
either so it breaks my heart because he
loves these Bears so much and he's just
asleep in his tent and one of them just
goes in and just enjo a midnight snack
man well that really play like just
demonstrates what a like foolish thing
it is to think that you can be friends
yeah with an apex predator like that or
to
anthropomorphize other kinds of animals
and like attribute qualities to them
that they do not have because like
totally I'm not I'm not saying he
deserved any I'm not saying that like oh
that's what you get but it's kind of
like I do think it's just like human
nature that humans always want to like
think that we have control it's like we
came after all of these I'm special like
this animal loves me when it comes to to
water and it's like no a tsunami is
going to be more powerful air like just
we think we're more powerful than
anything else and we're just idiots
that's why I really loved the movie nope
because that's the theme of the whole
movie is like you can't you know like
these are predators like you like the
whole theme of the film is you can't
tame a predator gosh yeah my my wife
Adrien loves bears dude dude like she's
like they're so cute and I'm like they
will literally eat you starting at the
stomach yeah like they'll just start at
the stomach and they'll ignore the agony
because they they don't care at all yeah
and that's the that's the way with a lot
of a lot of different stuff and yeah
it's kind of like the it's the main
character energy that like a lot of us
can easily fall into where it's like
well no I'm I'm Different like and
that's what this guy kind of viewed
himself as he like he's the one who's
going to bridge the gap between bear and
man yeah but like people who do like
Cults and stuff like they think that
they're like totally more powerful than
other people it's like animals don't do
that like they quite literally stay in
their Lane we're like the only like we
like to like pretend that we're these
people or like oh I'm Jesus today or
something of the sort Jesus today or
like or like my cat loves me it's like
well you feed
it yeah there's a scientific reason
behind say but like you know like you
die and your cat's going to eat you in
like three days I'm sorry my dogs love
me I can't allow this into my brain I'm
sorry no me I'm Different dude okay my
dog my dog love me okay no I can't I
mean they do they do there's affection
there but like yeah the instinct is
always stronger than that like whatever
human like connection you think is there
do you know what's funny like I I took a
shower this morning I know surprise uh
no and I I brought my dog into the
bathroom with me and I shut the door
behind me you have a dog uh I was dog
sitting so my my parents dogs
technically but I've had we had torture
yeah but the thing is like he's going
he's in closed the door and
just looked at him in
I was showering that's where it ended um
and so I was in there and I was just
thinking like wow uh if we were trapped
in this room would he ever turn on me
now like would he ever turn on me and
try to eat me if he got hungry enough I
had this thought this morning I don't
literally don't know that's shower
thoughts dude am I right I I do think
that like when it comes to house cats
and dogs they like they are so heavily
domesticated over time it does take more
unless they have those triggers so
sometimes you do have your dogs that do
have triggers but there's some that like
they're so they're so domesticated most
of them are going to be fine it's just
like they got to eat yeah you know
that's like the scariest [__] to me it's
like when I he hear about that stuff of
like people being found in the apartment
they dog you heard of this well they're
cats yeah cats but dogs dogs I'm not
sure would eat people maybe me neither I
don't think a dog would I think the dog
would comment below if you have
experience with this yeah do you are
have you our loved one scares me I mean
I'm like the I'm the most like my cat
loves me like person ever so like it
just that freaks me out thinking about
that okay wait so much so you're saying
that you've heard of people who've been
eaten by their cats if they pass away
and no one finds them and they can't
feed their cats the cats will feed on
them dang I mean as they should guess to
you know I I guess that is a kind of
romantic not it's a it's a poetic thing
like you he is now his human yeah I died
and now the cats will eat my
meat is my least favorite sentence of
the
day show this is a Halloween podcast
early Halloween podcast yes well that's
that's the thing is okay so we're
looking back through history right
chills not only cuz we're spoiled these
days we're spoiled in how we live we
live better than any King could dream
right the the average person for the
most part some Kings had like so many
slaves yeah that's that's true if that's
how you
living that's on my like those kings
imagine we never to lift a finger these
are people who would poop down the side
of the castle wall and that was like
that was luxury dude that was like a
Japanese toilet right there yeah if you
get like a six foot separation from what
you created that's Luxy so we just flush
it away well most of us yeah you know
it's pretty funny like seeing went to
gent over the summer and like there's
amazing Castle there the Gravenstein and
you can literally see the poop hole
still like oh the or the Kings well like
yeah but there's still stains of the
poop it's just like stain St it's like
scum stains but like it's just so funny
that like any commoner could just look
up and be like there's a king T in the
[__] but honestly just walk around
downtown and you'll also see yeah you
see that downtown too it's very much the
same Vibe if you think about it like in
some in some cultures being like
overweight or large is a sign of luxury
right it's like a showoff in a way like
look at the abundance that I have so two
was stained Stone if you had stained
Stone on your Castle then you know you
have a toilet and it's like that's the F
the stained Stone was more valuable than
regular Stone and this is all a lie
don't write this in your history paper
yeah don't please you'll get an f um if
you're citing this podcast in your paper
you're already getting you're already
sced we're screwed up like the kings and
queens they only wanted to eat white
bread and then the peasants ate the
brown bread but really the brown bread
was healthier yeah it was except for
yeah none of it was healthy cuz you're
eating rocks which sucked EA little
rocks cuz they grind it with like with
uh freaking millstones and those stones
would freaking I mean you're scraping
Stones against itself all day yeah so
you're going to get Le little that
little tiny sediment and that's what you
know that was very high in uh that's one
of the reasons that people had such bad
teeth cuz they were literally chewing
rocks all day oh my gosh um also no
dental hygiene also well a little bit
not very good yeah I mean don't do it
well it's different to see like the
different cultures like you know you
look at some cultures and they had much
better teeth because of their diet
totally more protein or herbs and I mean
probably just not eating bread in your
culture yeah and by extension not eating
rocks would probably help you going to
the dentist and that his his
prescription he's like you got to stop
EA just stop it just
stop talking about the worst ways to die
I feel like living anytime past 200
years ago was like also just dying
nightmare like slowly dying we made it
when we created gyms when you have to go
into a room and pretend to survive to
stay in shape like
run just on a freaking on something that
even has handles like we don't even run
literally it's a freaking machine it's
so funny to me watching people fake
survive yeah I mean think about it the
gyms are a thing because we're so like
sedentary now like we don't do anything
anymore yeah your foot is on a be and
it's funny because like you see well you
do see gyms in history but it's like and
then you look at like oh well it was the
Romans and they were also just as
sedentary kind of as we were like they
had these periods of peace and relative
luxury if you're living there and you
had some money when you look at like the
Game of Thrones era or like you know the
rich people
times again do not use do not write your
history paper based on this podcast
right dragons do not exist and you can
quote me on that but they will literally
be like let's take a walk around the the
garden and like that's there cuz they're
just like sitting there and they're like
knitting something and they just they
just walk and they're just in a dress
and I'm like I don't know how you guys
didn't die of like obesity but I guess
they doesn't have that much food I don't
know no yeah I mean it's kind of like if
you go like almost anywhere else in the
world but here and like people like walk
a lot and they like don't eat like huge
meals all the time and like they you
know I mean speaking of the old bread in
England like that's why they weigh in
stone like I don't know if you're aware
but it's like you know I'm I'm nine
Stone like that's how they actually
measure weight it's not in pounds or
grams or whatever it's in stone that's
what they were talking about dude I
lived there for two years I kept talking
about rocks I'm like what yeah it's I'm
I'm you know how many Stone and it's
because they would eat stones and you're
wondering how many stones that's what
I'm thank you okay I was wondering
another lie sorry last lie I'm done I'm
done lying now that is not but you are
measured that's that's another lie right
there you're done how many Stone are you
Stone am I me five Stone me five Stone
all the British people in the comments
are just like cringing so hard right now
I'm 14.5 Stone wow it's a lot of stones
means I'm so that means I'm like four
stone
you rude well now so we're doing weights
okay
on this podcast 14 St so someone yeah I
just realized someone can look that up
and that's unfortunate that I shared
that information uh but here we are
don't bully Jordan please oh there's
it's yeah how many
Stone so seven seven Stone per 100
pounds quick math so I'm like 11 stone
yeah there you go but either way like
nowadays we're living easy uh even the
ways that we're scared to die honestly
as brutal as they are are easy I mean at
least we got pain pillers to be honest
we we're dying because of like because
we can do things right
like we're dying for living we're like
oh a plane was invented therefore here's
another oh I see we're dying because we
can do things yeah cars it's our own
damn car own fault there's the we can
scuba dive cuz like that's a luxury if
you have time to scuba dive if you can
SC if you can scuba dive that means
you're doing pretty okay in life pretty
okay cuz other people like back in the
day they didn't have time to do anything
but work and just like try to live and
not get an infection they didn't have
time to go scuba dive and Cave dive and
go chase down Bears they're like we have
enough things on our backs that are
trying to kill us true like you were
just trying to fight off death every day
back there I mean whether it was cold
hunger the common cold like think you
are a witch yeah literally being a woman
often would get you killed to this day
yeah to this day when the like the life
expectancy was what like late 30s 40s
like unironically crazy like all of us
would be like elderly people had like
eight children by now and they would all
be Elders yeah and most of them would
have died Yeah by
now dude that's crazy we would be the
elders in the camp oh yeah dude I spit
so much like old Yarns you know just
like spitting yeah I feel like you don't
know like the older people were more
like on Asian cultures like Native
American cultures right like when you
think of like the Disney C movies that
made you never like really s like you're
old European people they were
DED that is crazy to think about know
new invention from there something to
that there's something to it being old
well like like apparently like in Norway
or like um Viking cultures some of them
they had this like ritual where you'd
like kill yourself once you got old to
not be bur to not be burden yeah yeah
I've heard of that like it's kind of
interesting it's like okay well if
resources are really if you're literally
living out in the wild right yeah like
in the snow elderly people I guess could
be taxing and a bur burden to the
community so they would literally like
everyone was cool with it they're just
like y now this my time like you can't
see you can't cook you can't do anything
we're just providing resources cuz
you're in a bed no if our should we do
that
now no just just just well like I I do
feel like in a way though it's it's a
bit nicer to be like hey you have that
option rather than be like hey do you
want us to like stick you in a
retirement facility where you're like
just going to sit down all day stare at
a wall in some country they they have
the option for for youth in Asia give me
the cliff man I would much rather sit in
a room all for like 10 years yeah there
was there was just one crazy case of
this person who had um like Unstoppable
pain it was like this weird nerve thing
or something and they they just couldn't
get away from it they just didn't want
to live anymore and in this country of
course you cannot choose to end your
life um and so they went to a different
country and there's like this chamber
that you get in and it like seals up
it's like a glass top and it basically
just puts you to sleep for goods up
nitren gas if you put a dog down yeah
kind of similar so that's an very
interesting you know way to go yeah I
mean that's if depending on because
again it's like the same idea of if if
you have like a bone cancer or something
that's really painful yeah like you just
have to write it out like that well you
know in like the elderly people who have
like dementia but like so far gone that
like it's far few in between like
they're ever even going to know who they
are and who is even coming into the room
but they can't give consent to just pass
away so they're just like living in like
a state of like fear and like
uncertainty constantly yeah it's like at
that point you don't even know what's
going on I think anyone who's listening
like like most people have probably had
experiences with family members with
dementia I know I have and or like you
know illnesses where it just drags on so
much it's like you know the person
doesn't want they're ready to end it and
it's like no we can't and usually it's
only for our sake hard a l like it's
yeah for people who aren't actually sick
we want them around longer and so that's
why like these rules are in place
because it's to make us feel good
meanwhile it's like if they really
really chose yeah yeah it's sad but I
think there is there is a freedom in
being able to choose when it's your time
to go the fact that we don't allow that
is pretty messed up there's another what
else is new well there's another version
of that same story like that happened in
this country where uh I I don't know if
it was the exact same disease or
whatever but they eventually uh ran away
and ended their life in a hotel alone
because they couldn't do it legally and
they didn't get to say goodbye to
anybody they just ran away so no one was
implicated in like assisting them what a
sad like that's so sad you know it is
yeah it's a crazy thing um but uh I
guess it's just like it's labeled a
suicide rather than what would it be
labeled and medically put down assisted
suicide assed suicide yeah so that's
very much a thing so or is the stake and
said was it I think just murder yeah
yeah me there used to be like even way
more stigma against suicide I mean all
the religious stigma against suicide was
insane I mean they would like there were
like certain burial protocols even where
if you committed suicide like I forget
what
there was I might be complaining this
with a Vampire one where they'd
like there's like all these weird burial
protocols like bro that's Twilight dude
there's so many burial protocols there's
one with a bell where like some people
ended up getting buried alive so they
started like it was fashionable to start
getting a bell installed in your coffin
just in case you're buried alive so you
could like happens way more fre yeah
know it it used to happen a lot because
like people just pass out and like you
know the guy at the morg would just like
oh yeah no P yeah you know they didn't
know it coma really was I
guess though I mean if it was low maybe
then this happened though enough for
people to start putting bells on their
graves well that's another way that I
don't want to die yeah no being buried
alive okay that's actually my worst oh
let's get into
it Griffin did I strike a court here
dude it is so English to have a little
bell and be like excuse
me you mind Lifting me out I'm quite
alive thank you very much EX I'd like to
come up now d d may I come home how
rude rude you might be
mistaken let let's dive into your
deep-seated fears around being buried
alive they are deep-seated yes no dude
it's just a fre F
that have you had a dream about it no I
just freaking saw it kill Bill and I was
like dang I hate that or that one movie
where they're buried alive the whole
time well there there was one there was
one um watch too scared was it the movie
called buried alive
yes there was one woman who was uh
excavated what's the word when they pull
him back up excommunicated
excommunicated from the coffin uh ex
zoomed ex zoomed and they opened it up
and uh basically she was like like this
and the entire underside of the coffin
was scratched that's like mummy [__]
right there like that's so creepy in the
mummy when when they see the nails of
Imhotep the nails he was trying to claw
his way out that might have been the
seed actually for me where I was like
just thinking about like
what fly your way out no one can hear
you and you have days dude it takes days
to starve well because are you starving
or are you running out of oxygen a
little bit both same I hope you carbon
dioxide or DEH hope that happens fast
how long does that take I don't know
actually shoot yeah you look like okay
yeah wait maybe it actually wouldn't be
as bad as I think it depends on how big
your area is so if you're dealing with a
coffin I think legit like you have like
two days cuz I watched I've watched like
the Law and Order episodes where the the
criminal has buried their victim alive
and they're like we only have 16 hours
or something like that ready I have the
answer a person can live on the air in a
coffin for a little over five hours oh
thank God okay you know what fear God
you're done C is much more you barely
have time to watch the extended uh Lord
of the Rings Return of the King so
here's a pro for buried alive if you're
only going to live five hours that means
you probably don't have to worry about
pee PE poo poo in the like you're not
going to be that's fear I was thinking
about how if you're in there for 2 days
it's like you are sitting in this coffin
you are soiling yourself the whole
you're probably so dehydrated it's like
are you even pooping I feel like at that
point the soiling is I I poop when I'm
SC at least you you know you got
something to do hour one just hour one
you've been down there for 20 minutes
and it's just fully soiled like what are
you doing Jordan it was just a prank I
thought it was over for me I just
thought it was over I mean cuz like you
know I a flight from Los Angeles to
Chicago like I probably take two
bathroom breaks but if I know that like
all I got is those five hours and then I
don't have to worry about it ever again
I can hold it yeah I hold it I try to
like some
dignity it's like your last cuz it feels
good to go to the bathroom we all know
this and let's just freaking address I'm
tired of pretending this not you have to
smell it I'm tired of pretend then you
have to smell it though but you know
what they're your last everybody likes
their own
has a last gas was air and you're
smelling your
urine gosh this is dark well luckily
none of this would actually need to
happen cuz we now know that you'd only
survive 5 hours you only survive 5 hours
I think it depends that com go longer
than 5S here for you okay what if you're
just cover like in a box underground in
a box underground in AAL well wait well
it's all the soil that's going to keep
the oxygen from getting down there right
it's not what kind of soil you talking
about you know know what I'm here's a
curveball for you now I know you like
working from home you know I know you
like you know Retreats out to the woods
you know just like some
Solitude what happens if you get in that
that coffin and you find out you
actually really like it and then you
realize you only have like five like 4
hours and 50 minutes left and now you're
really bumed oh so you mean like suicide
no no no this is like I feel at home
here yeah and now you're like you know
the the torture is it's just that I
don't have much time left yeah I mean
it's pretty similar to the torture this
comfy little box yeah no but does he get
out of it um run I feel he's trying to
confess
something in a roundabout way he's like
me too I was saving them so they'd be
beautiful
forever happy H so you're asking will he
does he get out of the coffin well I
think I initiate in my mind a sort of
Montage at that point where I was doing
different activities in the Box you know
to make it more memorable building
roll slightly I don't know what you can
really do you
know of the three things you can do I
can scream screaming rolling and soiling
hit my head on the ceiling little bit
ping pong just back and forth oh the the
memories we've
made some splinters under the fing
Montage yeah no I I think if I in that
case that would just be a really sad
death instead of a a scared one and I'd
I'd rather have i' rather a sad death
than a scared one well I'll give you a
scared
okay scared ones usually can end like
fast though I guess so I but like I'm
I'm so comforted by the fact that five
hours is all I'd have to be in the
coffin screaming getting murdered would
suck Mur I'm sure it does I'm on a I'm
sure yeah bro it probably does huh it's
that it's that moment when you realize
oh that person's murdering me like
there's a there's a thing like it's like
if anyone's ever like been in a fight or
like had someone like come at him it's
like like when you realize like oh
they're engaging M it's like that but
with holy shoot that's scary dude yeah
profanity
please holy [__] that's scary uh no so
I'm on this list of 10 10 of the worst
ways to die different no I want to list
of 10 of the worst ways to die because
again it's like hearkening back to how
things used to be like we're spoiled now
okay even our fears are spoiled which is
funny but at number two on this list
which blows my mind there's SK
oh
yeah so that fling yes that is was a
common practice because it was a way
they knew how to do it so like nicely
it's the same way if you go I think
nicely is the right no if you go um
hunting and you want to get the skin off
of a bear it's the same tactic but you
can keep the person alive so they would
be fully alive still at the end of
skinning and then they would put the
skin up on the wall to show other people
do not do this crime the the time of
death could be anywhere from a few hours
to a few days yeah for flying but at
number one on this list at least because
there's still a bunch that we didn't
talk about like getting buried up to
your neck and then ants eating you like
that's one that's yeah there's the the
death by Thousand Cuts is a famous one I
think that's a Chinese uh uh you like
die of infection or shock literally a
ton of little Cuts yeah and eventually
you die um and then there's one dude
there's one that I saw was it at the
Tower of London or somewhere I can't
remember good at the to but it's like
dude it's like a it's like a pyramid oh
you know what I'm talking about it's
long too so sharp edge that goes all the
way across and it just seesaws you from
your booty and just cuts you clean in
half there's you sit on it you sit on it
and it slowly cuts through you just the
I I don't know if it's the weight of you
that that cuts or if it moves back and
forth is that the one where they like
put weight
on yeah like over time the gravity like
a cheese
grater I don't know if it moves or not
but if it's not the cheese grater then
literally grab
cutting you over in half yeah and
there's a movie bone Tomahawk don't I
mean unless about that one dude they
flip a dude upside down they grab a leg
and they hack and literally rip into pie
okay it honestly is the worst thing I've
ever seen on film it made me physically
sick but none of those are number one
what's number one number one on this
list which you may agree or disagree I
don't know it's the Roman Candle have
you heard of this no big Roman history
yeah allow me to enlighten
first the victims were tied and nailed
feels excessive to tall Stakes then
flammable liquid was poured over them
before they were set a light the fire
started at the feet to prolong the
suffering mhm that's it yeah that's not
the worst over the booty wedge seriously
they're just tied to Stak they not even
put up their button out of their
shoulders they're tied to staks and
nailed getting burned alive cuz they
said that people would end up passing
out just from the heavy smoke dude
burned alive such a copout death because
yes just like Jordan said like most
people literally pass out after the
first couple seconds it's not that bad
it's not being cheese graded [__]
that burn of the steak that is a like
United Club like luxury like compared to
that no no honestly I I would take burn
at the steak any day man it would suck
for a while but not as long as many of
these things we've talked about and I
mean what doesn't kill you makes you
stronger so with the Positive light for
me dude put switch out number one with
the like bamboo one oh yeah the bamboo
one tell the I just heard there's one
like I think it was like an ancient
Chinese like torture or execution they'
like um I mean there's bamboo everywhere
they would stake you down on the ground
and then plant fresh bamboo under you
and in only a couple of days apparently
it would start growing through the
person bamboo is sharp so strong yeah
it's strong it grows super
fast Little Sprouts are they're like SHP
dude like and it imagine that it's like
the rat but even slower you know imagine
being the guy who invented that that and
it's being like I have an idea invented
planting bamboo he's like what have I
done think someone accidentally
discovered it like they fell asleep and
then they woke up they're
like [__] a long day of playing the
bamboo better go to sleep right here I'm
leave my bamboo right here don't move
don't move oh no uh it actually reminds
me of a story a personal story Nick I
told you this one dude but in high
school right the the idea of bamboo
growing through over time it's horrific
to me anything through yeah and in high
school I played basketball right and
when you play basketball you know you're
doing a lot of Stutter Step drills a lot
of stuff that is pushing the front of
your toes against your shoes oh no and I
developed an ingrown toenail right which
at the time I didn't know what it was I
it didn't mean anything to me and of
course as a high schooler I'm not going
to seek medical advice I'm just going to
deal with it and so over time I just got
used to limping I just got used to like
toe is just going through puberty first
like it's just getting really big yeah
dude it's just changing man I don't want
to talk about it don't look uh but it
got really sore like very red and like
dude when I say hyper sensitive to the
touch anything glazed on it Agony like
that sensitive but I I honestly just
ignored it thinking it would take care
of itself you know the innocence of
Youth and all uh anyway I'm going to run
to my room one day oh and I take a
little bit too wide of a step school
you're like I can't wait to play I can't
wait to play and I Crush my toe on the
door frame smack it right on the corner
right on the same corner and I literally
my body goes into full shock and I just
drop on the ground and I look up and the
nail had punctured through the front of
my toe sorry front so INR INR it grows
down it grows in so it's like if if
you're cutting your nails it grows like
it's a little too sharp for the side so
it starts to push into the side of the
skin and then it had gotten so deep that
it had actually punctured through and
then when I stubbed it it punctured all
the way through so it split out the end
his toenail all right that's number one
on the list now and it is the worst pain
I've ever felt in my life and I'm like
that was a little part of my toe can you
imagine through the center of your body
with bamboo bro like it it was yeah I
can't I literally can't I don't know
so school I played a lot of basketball
and my toe would like CR she stepped out
for that story and she's saying the same
thing yes did you get an ingrown toe
yeah ingrown it was like dying fungus
did it punch through your toe I I
basically they're like we need to remove
your big toenail so they put needles in
my toe same surgery to to numb me but
the numbing did not work it it same
story my screens were heard through the
halls I feel seen yeah they took they
removed my whole entire big toenail Jord
guys Michael Jordan had the same thing
and by the way um Pam was like around
the corner so I had nine toenails during
prom Pam yeah Pam yeah prom pam pam and
prog so I it was like all the girls were
getting their toenails done you getting
your toe done yeah getting
nine dud it was painted like a Lego face
it was the worst and it took a while to
grow back it was like a little nub that
that surgery though is no joke like they
not even surgery they put four needles
so I I immediately went to the hospital
but when mine went through the side like
got to the they're like okay we're going
to do this right now they lay me down
the four needles that go in each one
hurts worse than the other yeah and I
made a joke to him at the end I was like
good Lord man it felt like it was
hitting bone and he's like it was like
they're injecting into your toe and it's
literally tapping the bone of your toe
but mine didn't numb it mine didn't numb
it enough and they didn't take my whole
toe they took a knife and they severed
the K Griffin's done sorry everybody
they took the connect they severed the
connection with the scalpel of the nail
to the bed and then they took a clamp
they took a clamp and cracked it down
the middle with like a nutcracker dude
and they took half of it freak I hate it
dude I hate it but it's not the Roman
Candle so I'm positive did I get this
wrong so you have half of a big toe they
didn't take the toe oh
okay and P Pam was right around the
corner P was right around the corner my
TOA is back and nice but I always still
have issues with that toenail like it
always wants to get a little discolored
or like a little bit of like fungus
we've all noticed littleit thick like
when your nail kind of gets a growth and
it gets all thick yes it's like thicker
at the end it's always it's always this
guy extra strength toonol
yeah sometimes I'm like dang dude that's
you're getting too thick you're supposed
to grow out not up I have I have one
nail that's just like goes up but you'll
be happy to hear that nail stuff was
actually torture it was very it was a a
common torture to stick [__] in between
nails and we all know that feeling like
when you cut your nail Too Close
sometimes and it takes a couple days of
just pain but like I mean you ever had a
hang nail yeah exactly and it's like the
simplest thing I mean you don't need any
hardware for it poing down yeah
literally oh just taking a thing that
was a very popular one extra bad it's
every man's torture you know that one I
can empathize with I feel like sometimes
if you've ever like reached into like a
a pile of hay or straw or like into
grass and a blade of grass just like
perfectly lines up and goes like a
quarter millimeter under your nail like
yeah that sucks by itself so I just
thought of one imagine taking like a I
don't know some type of nail and a
hammer and like going on your bone and
like that was a way of torturing was
someone just hammering all your B going
to hammer a nail his Bon he's going to
turn my Bon imagine that feeling but it
like it goes up your nerves like up your
spinal cord dude N I don't want that was
the thing actually like breaking every
bone was a very common one in people
enjoy it wasn't I'm telling you it
wasn't about getting information not
that many
people had information to give like they
were just like peasants no it was about
sending a message for sure the ordeal
the wheel was a big one sorry it was
breaking on the wheel cuz they literally
tie you to Wagon Wheel and they turn it
and then you just well they break the
the Executioner would and this was
reserved for like this was the worst
punishment there was and people were
super scared of it for good reason you
know that's like this was for like the
child murderers or the people who who
forged currency which was actually like
one of the worst crimes you could do
back then cuz it was like sanctioned by
the king whatever but alwaysone so those
people would get broken on the wheel and
they would you know usually sometimes
they'd have hang you if you're lucky but
they' tie you to a wheel big Wagon Wheel
right and then the Executioner comes
around with a club and proceeds to break
all your bones like everyone except for
your head well maybe the head but oh
that I don't think they do that because
they want to keep you alive oh and they
turn you in do a little Jiggly Wiggly
guy on there and then jell shots and
then it seems like the common theme is
stick them up on a hole and let them
just hang there that's where the
creativity ends it's like do the pole
thing I saw a different one on the wheel
they like attached them to the wheel and
then they turn the wheel so that your
legs and your arms would just start
going that's probably one in all of them
so just imagine your bones are just
cracking as you like turn around inside
of a wheel like you know what I mean
like if you like put your like legs all
throughout the spokes
of of a wheel it sucks man sorry dude
that's
[__] you know what's pretty like up up
there with a lot of these is like you
know it's a different genre of of uh
horrific death but like a lot of
industrial accidents are kind of in the
same vein like d de gloving de gloving
hearing stories about
people when the skin just comes off
don't Google it don't Google it don't
Google it it's like like often what
happens like say like you get your
wedding ring stuck in a machine right
and it it tears from The Ring yes
careful Jordan I'm just going to hold it
it tears the ring and all your skin off
with it and you just get a little bone
and some meat have you ever eaten a
chicken leg it's kind of like have you
ever eaten a chicken like it's like when
you you pull the skin off the foot it
does that with your hand it pulls all
the skin off like a glove like it's de
gloving your hand you touching chemicals
Noz just gets caught it's like a
mechanical accident it gets like stuck
in like a gear and it like pulls your
freaking skin off dude that's brutal
well the coal miners but they kind of
died like over
time
like not even correlated at all well the
coal miners I would not want to be one
of them I agree with that it's the
machines that the the ones that Crush
stuff or like um or like the the
Grinders maybe the cold Crusher you know
once you get like hooked in it it pulls
you in that kind of stuff might be the
worst in the world here's the one that
like really messes me up there was a um
I I cannot I should probably just look
it up to not be lazy but there was this
crew that was working on um a like part
of an oil
rig I believe it was like one of the
pipelines that brings the crude like up
to the rig and they had to go in um to
this weird diving bell that they had to
put over the top of this pipe section to
take the end off and then you know
there's like a a plug that they had to
let go like they had to release so they
could kind of get in there and like you
know fiddle around fiddle some stuff up
so they're in this submerged diving bell
which if you're listening and you don't
know what a diving bell is it's just
take a cup underwater um you know from
the surface and push down so there's air
trapped in there and that's pretty much
it it's just an artificial bubble of air
so that you know the the maintenance
divers could work without you know
having to wear a mask and a respirator
and so these guys they get down there
and it it horrifically this is captured
on GoPro footage but I believe it was
four or six men were down there and
they're in the diving bell they're
working on it they release the cap they
release the plug and something happens
if if you're interested you know you can
you can look more into this but in a
fraction of a second a like pressure
differential caused a vacuum that
instantly sucked like all six of these
men down this tube and like how big is I
think it was like 36 in across maybe
down into the depth down yeah it it
sucked them like hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of feet down this tube and
uh unfortunately sadly only one of the
men was able to escape how how did he
how heck did he did he like hold on to
something no no no so like they ended up
they ended up trapped in this this
Pipeline and they are completely
disoriented they have no idea how at
what point in this massive pipeline they
are um but it is like a an L-shaped or
like a U-shaped pip they all survived
getting sucked through for a while they
were yeah no they they all survived some
of them were horrifically injured well
you if you get sucked and it like breaks
your back yeah cuz you like hit
a this is what Mario Mario's ORD
basically like the like a couple of the
least injured like the people closer to
one end they picked a direction because
they were like we're either crawling the
exact opposite direction and we will die
die down here or we're crawling closer
to the entrance and they just had to
like shimmy and just like crawl and only
one guy was able to make it out
unfortunately me dude no thank you that
that might be the worst one What's this
called the oil rig of 20 let me look it
up really quick uh Mr Ballin did a
really really good episode on it oh dude
getting like yeah pulled into voids is
one of the scariest thing like uh just
there's like that video of the guy the
sewage worker who like got sucked into a
like a water super and he just passed
away dude like like it was so quick uh
here we go where do they go it is the uh
the Pariah diving
disaster the what the Pariah diving
disaster it's a video on YouTube yeah
you can look it up um yes do I want to I
kind of want to watch it but I don't
know if you want like the real facts
that are not like you know kind of miss
you know I'm sure got history paper yeah
it it's yeah it's messed up industrial
accidents are messed up I was really
hoping that this would be therapeutic
you know like we'd work our way through
this and then this is just just awoken
so many more fears for me really I'm it
actually kind of puts some to bed for me
the whole like the whole Dy in 5 hours
being bared alive yeah that's a relief
if there's a silver line need to take
away guys it's that if you get buried
alive you'll die in five hours so let's
just all dwell on that that positive
I'll take a gunshot glass half full I'll
take Gun Crazy I'll just take a full
life ding in as sleep please yeah inject
me inject me oh you're still choosing
not okay because I said D in your sleep
natural you still want the injection oh
I well cuz here's the thing if you are
if you're going to get injected you kind
of know when it's happening you'll see
you want the Power of
Choice yeah yeah I think yeah I don't
know if I want to choose when I die I
don't know it's hard that's a whole
other
podcast I'm super good not dying right
now and I I don't see that changing but
if it does you know I'm I'm down to be
flexible but what what kind of matters
right now you free Wednesdays at 5 give
me a really comfy coffin and I'll just
our next appointment's next next Tuesday
can you hold off the the takeaway from
me here is all these horrific things
have happened throughout history they're
not happening to us right now let's be
grateful for the moments that we have
and enjoy this Halloween together with
the ones that we love and don't go cave
diving and don't stay away from caves
just overall bad idea my quick takeaway
is that all these horrible deaths must
have created some really [__] up
ghosts and they're still out there and
they could be in your closet so happy
let's let's get to hunting yeah you know
someone's got to do it what's your take
away final thought's your take away my
takeaway um you know yeah no one is
truly the main character in the world
and there are a lot of things that are
more powerful and more final than us but
it is something that is good to be
cautiously aware of but not ruled by as
life is still a beautiful gift worth
living uh yeah my heart goes out to all
of the people affected by the horrific
things we talked about today you know
even though we're joking around and
we're making light you know uh seriously
tragic stuff and uh Happy Halloween
everyone uh investigate Jordan Allen
there is something seriously wrong with
his crawl space yeah it's been a problem
hypers specific yep just stay away from
it there's nothing there it's boring
Jordan can you takeaways oh I about to
say goodbye man I don't know what's my
takeaway I think you just don't quite
know
anyone what wow I guess I did she looks
into the camera all right well that's my
takeaway o okay there Christian well
happy Halloween and uh try to get some
sleep good luck enjoy your life
nightmare nightmare nightmare